jetzt aber kommen wir zu Ihrem Thema
jetzt reden wir über die WM in Katar wir
hatten hier auch waldemar Hartmann
sitzen er sagte lasst mir doch endlich
meinen Fußball den Fußball der muss
Fußball bleiben ich will keine Politik
auf dem Spielfeld sie sagen aber diese
WM die muss Folgen haben ihre Zeit ja
zunächst mal Waldemar Hartmann den ich
sehr schätze das ist nicht dein fußball
ist unser Fußball also auch meiner und
der Fußball von vielen Menschen auch von
gleichgeschlechtlichen Menschen ist das
genauso der Fußball und es geht
natürlich darum dass wir in Zusammenhang
mit Katar nach der WM viele Dinge
aufarbeiten und viele Dinge diskutieren
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass wir nach
der WM eine Debatte kriegen ob die FIFA
so wie wir sie im Moment erleben noch
Sinn macht ob das noch ein Verband ist
den wir brauchen ob wir nicht in der
Lage sind Weltmeisterschaften das ist ja
so die ureigenste Aufgabe der Fieber
auch anders zu organisieren ich glaube
bei dieser WM sind ganz ganz viele Dinge
schief gelaufen auch am Ende die Mund zu
Kampagne fand ich eher unglücklich wir
müssen und wir werden nach der viele
viele Diskussionen haben hätte man die
WM in diesem mehr als homophobenland gar
nicht erst veranstalten dürfen
also ich war ja selbst da vor drei
Wochen mit der bundesinnenministerin und
wir hatten Gespräche geführt und das ist
auch das enttäuschende Gespräche waren
sehr sehr gut aber es ist nichts
passiert anschließend es gab Zusagen die
wurden sogar schriftlich fixiert und es
ist danach ganz viel gehandelt worden
was nichts mit dem zu tun hatte was wir
besprochen haben ich glaube das Problem
fängt viel früher an es wird eine WM wie
in Katar wird so in der Form nicht mehr
geben weil die Fieber hat ja auch ihre
Regularien geändert und Menschenrechte
sind ja jetzt ein Bestandteil der
Kriterien aber
insgesamt auch das Verhalten der Fieber
während der WM diese One Love findet
dieses Thema das war ja schon der
abgeschwächte Kompromiss gegenüber Katar
und dann und auf und dann wurde
ausgerechnet die Fieber ist dann noch
den Diener von Katar und verbietet auch
noch diese Bilder obwohl sie seit drei
Monaten davon wussten selbst in unserem
Gespräch mit Infantino war die Binde
auch ein Thema und da wurde das nicht
thematisiert und zwei Tage vorher wird
das gecanceltino
viel viel Redebedarf haben nach dieser
Wertung immer einmal auch bei uns hier
nach Deutschland tragen sie sind
Spielerberater sie haben den FSV
Frankfurt in die zweite Liga dennoch ist
es auch hier so
dass vizionalspieler haben die sich
outen warum ist das so ja weil es nach
wie vor wir dürfen uns ja nichts
vormachen also es bringt auch nichts
wenn wir mit dem Finger auf andere
Nationen zeigen natürlich gibt es bei
uns im Land auch noch Probleme jetzt
sind wir wieder bei unsere
kerndiskussion hier ist auch nicht alles
rosig und jetzt auch nicht alles gut
aber der entscheidende Unterschied ist
bei uns können homosexuelle Menschen
frei leben die brauchen keine Angst
haben ich will nur wissen warum ist es
bei uns soweit laut weil ich vielleicht
noch Angst haben weil ich vielleicht
Angst haben meiner Ansicht nach müssen
nicht ich kenne auch einige und rede
auch mit ihnen darüber und aber es ist
deren Entscheidung weil letztendlich ist
das natürlich auch ungeheuriger Druck es
kommt ja dann immer dieses Argument wenn
du dann den Stadion einläuft schreien
vom Gegner 40.000 homo oder du schwuler
ja dann sage ich den immer das machen
sie auch so egal ob du schwul bist also
aber das ist verstecken
ich sage Ihnen auch warum weil das ist
die schönste Zeit deines Lebens also
irgendwo wissen wir alle zwischen 15 und
35 gut 59 ist jetzt auch eine sehr
schöne Zeit 60 entschuldigung aber ich
sage den immer du verschenkst die
schönste Zeit deines Lebens mit dem
Versteckspiel das muss dir doch deine
Seele zerreißen
und fragen Sie
ich habe Leute die mit mir darüber reden
und ich versuche den das immer zu sagen
ich sage aber auch das ist am Ende deine
Entscheidung du musst das für dich
selbst entscheiden das kann niemand
anders für dich entscheiden oft ist es
so dass die neben privaten Umfeld auch
geoutet sind ja aber eben nicht
öffentlich ich habe aber gesagt
Kampfsport auch so ich habe auch einen
Fußballverein mit 800 Mitglieder gerade
in FSV Buckenberg wo die meisten
deutsche Aussiedler sind
da lerne ich dass sie Zivilcourage haben
aber von unserer Nationalspieler
verlangen wir das nicht ich erwarte von
denen dass ein Torhüter der schon alles
erreicht hat alles erreicht hat die
Binde einfach dran ist und wenn die FIFA
mich bestraft weil ich da für bin dass
jeder Mensch so sein soll wie er sich
fühlt dann sollen sie mich bestrafen ich
war ein Kinderheim ich habe 14 Jahre im
Kinderheim und habe acht Revolutionen
geführt alle verloren aber ich war
wenigsten glücklich dass ich sie geführt
habe und das muss man wieder lernen dass
wir unsere Jugend sagen Toleranz ist
wichtig für uns
Respekt ist wichtig und hilfsbereit ist
wichtig das sind die Säulen des Fußballs
und das wird gerade eingerissen total
eingerissen nur wegen Katar das sage ich
ganz offen diese und Doppelmoral geht
mir wirklich an die Nerven vorbei zu
sagen guckt alle Fußball ne guckt kein
Fußball an Anführungszeichen
Entschuldigung weil Katar so schlimm ist
aber nebenbei tun man dann Gas kaufen
also das ist ungefähr so Bernd ist
ungefähr so ich sage raucht nicht und
nebenbei durch Zigaretten verkaufen das
geht nicht das geht und da müssen wir
Klartext reden wir dürfen unsere Jugend
so nicht versauen und FIFA versaut
unsere Kinder und da sage ich jetzt ist
aber Schluss jetzt kriegen sie die Kante
Funktion